et pour en parler nous sommes avec
vanessa saaba rédactrice en chef du
magazine psychoenfants vice présidente
d'enfance majuscule bonsoir vanessa sa
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
pascal cusi qu avocat président de
l'association un coup de pouce
protection de l'enfance bonsoir m kozik
merci d'être un génie également donc
chaque jour en ce moment une révélation
choc qui donne la nausée en matière
d'inceste ou de violences sexuelles sur
mineurs les français sont sous le choc
il n'y a pas d'autre mot vanessa saab la
question qu'on peut se poser pourquoi
seulement maintenant alors que pour je
le dirai pas la plupart mais en tout cas
de ces affaires très médiatique on
apprend que ç'a eu lieu il ya des années
pourquoi on sort du silence maintenant
ces révélations maintenant je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose vraiment de
l'ordre du culturel c'est à dire que oui
ça vous avez raison ça fait ah ben ça
fait des années et des années que ces
affaires sont dans les familles sont
sont enterrés dans le silence et je
crois que ya ses fans qui se lève ces
femmes qui décident de parler il ya une
mouvement mis tous maintenant le
mouvement me points c'est ce qui est
suivi par ce mouvement science pork sur
les réseaux sociaux
peut-être que les réseaux sociaux
facilitent aussi la libération de la
parole parce qu'il ya une forme
d'anonymat
pour certains tous les cas et donc oui
il ya quand même un mouvement de société
qui se lèvent face à face à la lourdeur
du silence c'est sûr alors ce sont bien
évidemment aussi les révélations de
camille kouchner qui a accusé on le
rappelle son beau-père médiatique le
journaliste constitutionnaliste olivier
duhamel d'avoir violé son frère jumeau
qui ont été un tournant pas un cas isolé
malheureusement on va regarder ces
chiffres ensemble d'après l'institut
ipsos en 2020 un français sur dix ce
chiffre est vertigineux affirme avoir
été victime d'inceste 6,7 millions de
français précisément déclare avoir été
victime d'inceste en 2021
depuis 2009 les chiffres de l'inceste en
france ont triplé pascal cusi ghlin
cesse est un phénomène tabou dont on ne
mesure n'est pas dont on ne mesure pas
l'ampleur
ben je crois que la difficulté aussi
c'est qu'on ne veut pas voir parce que
les enquêtes sur ce fléau qu'est
l'inceste elle existe depuis longtemps
et moi je suis étonné aujourd'hui quand
on entend les prises de paroles de
monsieur paquet de monsieur dupont
moretti
dernièrement de voir à quel point
l'inceste et l'oublié du départ quoi
c'est à dire que l'on souhaite poser un
interdit en retenant un seuil d'âge à 15
ans mais on oublie le cas de l'inceste
comme si comme 6 à 15 ans et un jour un
enfant pouvait consentir un acte
incestueux donc donc ce fléau blain
c'est ce qu'on connaît on a déjà les
chiffres qui sont effrayants du nombre
de victimes
il est temps maintenant que les
politiques regardent ça en face et
prenne des dispositions pour qu'on sorte
d'un système qui est un système de quasi
impunité des violences sexuelles sur
mineurs en général on va en reparler
pascal cuisine évidemment c'est très
intéressant puisque le gouvernement
semble alors vous justement vous ne
dites pas qu'il s'en empare mais tout de
même il ya eu des réactions politiques
et légales on va en reparler dans
quelques instants mais je voudrais
rebondir justement sur ce silence
vanessa saab qui est assourdissant ce
silence parce que quand on s'intéresse à
ces affaires on se rend compte cette
phrase terrible que tout le monde entre
guillemets savez ça dit quoi ce silence
et notamment jusqu'à dans l'entourage
en fait ce silence il est presque
générique c'est à dire qu'il se ça se
pose dans les familles
concernant l'inceste ça se pose quand ça
touche toutes les institutions l'église
l'enseignement la science po je dirais
même ça touche les parlementaires l'état
tout ce qui est sous forme d'institution
finalement le silence permet de tenir
l'institution et donc quand
les victimes de violence quelle qu'elle
soit très préserve l'institution et à
l'agresseur qui a qui a qui a une de la
l'emprise sur lui qu'il ya de la
domination sur lui et du coup le la
victime elle veut aussi préserver
l'institution et quand on est témoin
comme la dans cette affaire frédéric
millions qu'il a su en 2018
eh bien il préfère penser enfin préfère
ne pas croire ce qu'on lui a dit et
pensé autre chose pour préserver
l'institution donc on est dans un
système qui préserve institutions que ce
soit l'institution familiale tous types
d'institutions et on a beaucoup de mal à
avancer aujourd'hui comme le disait
pascal cul sic concernant la protection
des mineurs parce que là encore il ya
tout un système de pouvoir c'est très
compliqué d'avancer sur des choses
essentielles
parce que l'institution est à préserver
avant tout parce que quelques ex jusqu'à
présent c'est évidemment à l'avocat que
je m'adresse cette impunité vent dont
vous parliez c'est ça qui a favorisé
aussi ce silence la loi n'était pas du
tout adaptée et laissait finalement la
victime dans un isolement très cruel
c'est sûr que quand quand les victimes
savent que leur parole va être remise en
doute systématiquement et qu'on va
discuter systématiquement dans des
affaires de viol de leurs consentements
possible ça n'incite pas beaucoup a
alerté la justice et a déposé plainte
on en avait on a encore jusqu'à ce jour
un système juridique qui oblige les
tribunaux dans chaque affaire de viol a
discuté de la question de la contrainte
et du consentement possible de l'enfant
les magistrats le font quotidiennement
parce que la loi n'impose parce que
quand on ouvre le code pénal français on
se rend compte que la contrainte et à
caractériser y compris lorsqu'il s'agit
d'un enfant victime très jeunes ou d'un
enfant victime d'inceste
donc cette question de la contrainte
aléas les récurrentes danser dans ces
débats on le voit dans la sphère julie
dont vous avez parlé dans votre
reportage est forcément que ça donne un
système qui offre en quelque sorte une
voie royale aux agresseurs vers
l'impunité et c'est de ce système là que
le pignon public ne veut plus
aujourd'hui parce qu'on se rend bien
compte que discuter du consentement d'un
enfant de 6 ans ou dix huit ans ou même
d'un enfant plus jeune lorsqu'il est
victime de son père ou de son grand
frère par exemple c'est un défi au bon
sens et le droit ne peut pas à ce point
être déconnecté des réalités
vanessa savez une réplication justement
avant de parler de cet aspect très légal
qui va être important ces prochaines
années vous parliez de ce hashtag ainsi
en sport la parole qui se délient un
tout doucement les démissions des uns et
des autres notamment du directeur de
sciences po ça veut dire quoi que ce
cette omerta elle était particulièrement
dans ces milieux très très élitiste on a
tous évidemment pas beaucoup ont lu ce
livre de camille imaginaire s'il ya des
mécanismes ayant des mécanismes
d'emprise c'est à dire que en fait dans
toutes ces affaires là elle en parle
très bien calmé kouchner dans son livre
elle était sous le charme de duhamel
mais au-delà de ça le silence y vient
aussi l'omerta elle vient de ce système
d'emprise où finalement ben en face on a
il ya un fait un faible ayant un fort il
ya un sachant et il ya un apprenant et
il y a y'a comme ça dans toutes les
institutions il y à un système comme ça
d'emprise où il y en a un qui sont
inférieures à l'autre et ça et ça permet
le silence c'est à dire que en fait
l'autre sachant mieux ce qu'il faut
faire quand il nous dit qu'il faut qu'il
faut se taire et ben il faut se taire et
cali kouchner halal est là elle a mis
beaucoup d'années à écrire ce livre a
attendu la mort de sa mère pour écrire
ce livre et on voit bien que dans tout
chez toutes les victimes
parler c'est un travail qui se fait
qu'ils aient de qui prend des années
souvent c'est un don dit tiens elle a
parlé de 30 ans où il a parlé quarante
ans après mais en réalité c'est quelque
chose qui est
vraiment compliqué parce que il ya des
systèmes de loyauté il ya des systèmes
de l'intérieur de ces agressions de
silence aussi qui protège la victime de
silence qui protège l'agresseur c'est
très complexe sur le plan psychologique
et l'emprise c'est très complexe parce
que justement ça mélange tout ça et
qu'il faut des années pour en sortir
fois avoir une maturité avoir fait peut
parfois un travail psychologique pour
arriver en sortir alors pascal qu' il ya
un face à ce phénomène vous le disiez le
gouvernement veut toucher aux seuils
d'âge ce sera 15 ans a dit hier le
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti est ce que l'introduction d'un
âge minimum de consentement en france
suffira-t-il à protéger ses enfants
contre les abus sexuels m alors
l'introduction d'un seuil d'âge de non
consentement est absolument
indispensable pour pour enfin
contrairement à ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure qu'on ne discute plus de
la question de la contrainte
concernant des mineurs de moins de 15
ans maintenant par rapport à l' annonce
qui a été faite par le gouvernement sur
ce seuil d'âge de 15 ans je serais pas
aussi affirmatif que vous sur le fait
que ce sera effectivement à ce village
de 15 ans parce que on nous a sorti du
chapeau hier une nouvelle condition qui
serait la différence d'âge de 5 ans
entre l'agresseur et la victime
donc ça veut dire que si l'agresseur à
18 ans et qu'un jour et que lille
agresse sexuellement d'une jeune femme
par exemple de 14 ans et bah ça ne
rentrera pas dans la nouvelle infraction
qui a été annoncé puisqu'il n'ya pas les
cinq ans d'écart d'âge
donc on annonce en grande pompe un seuil
d'âge à 15 ans mais on se rend compte en
introduisant comme ça des exceptions
comme celle ci est cette condition de
l'écart d'âge on se rend compte qu'en
réalité de fait le vrai seuil de non
consentement il va plutôt est à 13 ans
est-ce qu'il ya que en dessous de 13 ans
quand se posera jamais la question de la
contrainte donc je trouve ça presque
cynique de la part du gouvernement
d'aller annoncer un seuil à 15 ans
et de rajouter une condition qui fait
qu'en réalité le seuil véritable il sera
plutôt à 13 et 7
cette condition de différence d'âge va
poser une multitude de problèmes parce
que si on ne réglemente pas le cas de
l'inceste
ça veut dire que un grand frère de 17
ans pourrait agressé sa petite soeur de
14 ans et demi il n'ya pas les 50
différence d'âge
donc ça ne sera pas considéré comme un
crime et puis indépendamment des cas
d'inceste encore une fois voilà un jeune
majeur de 18 ans qui agresse une mineure
qui a entre 13 et 15
ça ne sera pas non plus considéré comme
un crime et on ne sait même pas
d'ailleurs si si ça sera encore
considéré comme un délit annexe à poney
ça faisait monde oui oui offerte à mener
votre âge et le frère elle gère aussi
peiné face à de sa pause oui là je
disais que ça allait poser d'énormes
difficultés juridiques et que là où on
est censé poser un interdit fort et
clair en ouvrant autant d'exceptions
eh ben on pose un interdit qui n'est
plus du tout fort qui n'est plus du tout
clair vanessa sable vous voyez sourire
vous quand j'ai cité cette loi de sortie
du chapeau de d'eric dupond-moretti
efficaces ont pas selon vous ben je je
suis d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
monsieur puis sic et surtout ce ça me
fait réagit en disant mais comment se
fait-il que encore aujourd'hui on est à
se battre et d'ailleurs ça fait des
années moi je fais donc je suis vice
présidente d'enfance majuscule aussi
créé une association de protection des
enfants qui existe depuis 1956 et on se
bat bec et ongles pour obtenir des
textes qui sont là pour protéger nos
enfants et on se rend bien compte que là
aussi à une préservation d'une
institution et à une lenteur étatique il
ya une difficulté étatiques à protéger
les enfants
donc c'est pour ça que je souriais parce
que ça revient à ceux dont je parlais
qui est que ce système en fait d'omerta
ceci ce système de dénis parce qu'on a
eu un mitri de l'unss est très fort et
donc on n'a pas non plus de mesures sur
l'inceste encore très clair annoncées
par le gouvernement
donc le système de dénis et les
génériques il est global ils touchent
les familles
il touche l'état il touche les toutes
les institutions et tous sciences po
donc je souriais à cause de ça c'est
parce qu'on est pas encore ce qu'on n'a
pas encore on n'est pas encore arrivé au
bout on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
j'en veux justement vous me demandez la
perche pour la prochaine question
pourquoi la france at-elle autant tardé
aborder ces lois ce consentement ce
débat sur l'âge du consentement pense
que tous les autres pays occidentaux en
noix sur l'âge du consentement pascal qu
zik pourquoi autant de temps en france
un pays supposés quand même moderne mais
si c'est une très bonne question je suis
pas sûr d'avoir la réponse
ce que je constate simplement c'est que
en 2018 lorsque la question avait déjà
été soulevée au moment du vote de la loi
schiappa on avait entendu de belles
déclarations d'intention sur le fait qu'
il ne fallait plus que le consentement
de l'enfant soit au coeur du débat
devant les tribunaux on s'est rendu
compte que la loi schiappa n'avait en
fait en rien transcrit dans la loi les
belles annonces qui avaient été faites
en renvoyant systématiquement la notion
de discernement donc toujours un examen
au cas par cas et là j'ai l'impression
qu'on est en train de revivre un épisode
un peu similaire c'est à dire qu'on fait
de belles annonces sur un seuil de 15
ans et puis on nous introduit des
exceptions sur la connaissance de l'âge
sur la différence d'âge entre l'auteur
et la victime qui va finir par vider de
sa substance le l'interdît fort et clair
qu'on était censé poser donc
donc on est dans cette difficulté de de
constater que malgré les belles
déclarations d'intention au moment de
passer à l'acte il ya toujours une
difficulté pour que les choses soient
transcrite dans la loi alors que
certains pays ont résolu cette question
depuis longtemps en angleterre il ya un
âge de non consentement depuis 60 ans
donc on en a un retard considérable sur
la question de nombreux pays l'allemagne
la belgique le canada la tunisie depuis
2010 est ont adopté des âges de non
consentement parfaitement clair sans
prévoir une
titude d'exception qui ne sont là que
pour protéger les adultes
donc je ne comprends pas qu'on ne soit
pas en mesure nous de regarder un petit
peu ce qui se passe ailleurs et de
s'inspirer des des autres droits pour
enfin avoir un système de protection de
l'enfance qui soit digne de ce nom
mais manifestement on n'aura pas la
réponse aujourd'hui vanessa saab
une de mes dernières questions qu'est ce
qui est prévu du côté de la victime pour
la reconstruction
justement de ces victimes souvent isolés
qu'est ce qui est prévu sur le plan
légal oui d'une manière générale ce
qu'on a parlé de la répression du côté
de la loi en france
pour l'auteur des faits mais est ce que
la douleur de la victime ait pris
suffisamment en compte dans notre pays
et sa reconstruction surtout non je
crois qu'on mesure pas encore
concrètement finalement les impacts je
crois qui est qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui comprennent pas quel est
l'impact psychologique des agressions
sexuelles sur sur les mineurs et sur les
femmes les traumatismes que ça génère
les effractions psychique les
déstabilisations il n'y a pas de prise
en charge qui est organisé par l'état
malheureusement donc c'est les
associations qui met ça en place
moi j'aimerais bien rebondir sur votre
question quand même qui est que la
france a des spécificités par rapport
aux autres pays
camille kouchner en parle il ya mai 68
qui explique un certain nombre de choses
il ya aussi la place de la psychanalyse
en france en france et et ça c'est ces
singuliers il n'y a que deux pays qui
option qui donne à la psychanalyse cette
place là et avec tout ce que la
psychanalyse peut comporter tout ce
qu'elle a pu aider mais c'est tout ce
qu'elle a pu comporter aujourd'hui qui
est dépassé aussi avec le fantasme des
enfants la notion de l'oedipe qui a
évolué qui est plus exactement celle qui
existait donc tous au courant libertaire
est encore là et en fait le droit
français est encore très marquée par
tous au courant libertaire je pense que
pascal cul sic ne me contredira pas mais
beaucoup d'experts c'est des
psychanalystes qui sont entendus par les
tribunaux dans les affaires et ça ça
ralentit énormément
là ça ralentit la prise en charge ça
crée des impunités sacré des ont dit que
l'enfant était peut-être qu'on s'entend
donc tout ça c'est dépassé et il ya
quelque chose à faire aussi sur le plan
psychologique de manière globale et sur
sur lesquels sont les experts entendus
devant les tribunaux faudrait qu'ils
aient un expert pluridisciplinaire des
experts pluridisciplinaires mai mais
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui de donner
la voix qu'il ya eu un seul un seul
courant de psychologie le maderna
question est le mode f1 pour vous pascal
cusi qu une prise de conscience
réellement il y aura un avant et un
après je reviens ma première question
avec l'espoir peut-être de loi qui
évolue évidemment de répression bien
d'en parler mais aussi dans le sens de
la victime
l'espoir oui bien sûr on l'a et puis
notamment en voyant que des propositions
de loi avait été déposée par madame
santiago notamment ou même par madame
alexandra louis qui préconise de retenir
un seuil d'âge à 15 ans et un seuil
d'âge à 18 ans en cas d'inceste sans
multiplier à côté des exceptions donc
l'espoir oui il existe et on se dit que
la france va pouvoir être
perpétuellement à la traîne de ses
voisins maintenant on a appris à être
extrêmement vigilant parce que ça soit
en 2018 ou ou compte tenu des annonces
qui ont été faites hier
je crois que la vigilance est de mise
parce que on se rend compte qu'il ya
encore de grands grands mouvements de de
réticence à adopter une vraie culture de
protection de l'enfant merci en tout cas
tous les deux vanessa saab
pascal cuisine d'avoir été avec moi
merci